[Música]
[Aplausos]
y hablarles de varias cosas pero varias
cosas que hacen parte de una misma
de lo complejo y de lo simple que viene
hablar de mi proyecto
mi proyecto
está allí entrecomillado
y no es casualidad
que mi proyecto se llame igual que mi
nombre de pila se llama carlos díaz
bandrés así se llama mi proyecto
es una
oportunidad
es un poquito más allá de un anhelo de
un deseo
lo complejo lo simple
allí se observan algunas personas
reunidas escuchando a alguien escuchando
la figura de lo que se supone debería
ser un mentor
todo en algún momento de nuestra
existencia hemos recibido una mentoría
me imagino que para la mayoría de los
presentes como latinoamericanos ha sido
una experiencia accidentada accidentada
digo porque no se planifica no es que yo
voy y le pido yo quiero que sea mi
mentor que asuma la mentoría del camino
que yo voy a recorrer entonces vamos un
poco de accidente en accidente
descubriendo nuestro camino lo complejo
no es más que eso que me llevo a lo
simple y lo simple viene siendo toda la
suma de lo complicado simplificarse es
un
un camino bien
difícil difícil
seguramente en alguna por lo menos en
una oportunidad de su vida le han dicho
esta frase tú tienes que
y lo hemos escuchado de familiares lo
hemos escuchado de personas que nos
quieren tu tienes que hacer esto o tú
tienes que hacer aquello tú tienes que
y resulta que tú tienes que si tienes
que hacer algo pero si quieres y si
puedes
y todos los que están acá en este
auditorio y los que me observan son
personas de grandes capacidades y esa
energía interior
les dice esa energía esa voz interior
les dice que tienen a veces más
capacidades de las que tenemos o de la
que queremos y si quieres y si puedes
poder es capacidad
si puedo yo si puedo tú sí puedes pero
si quiero eso es lo más importante y si
quiero entonces si la condicionante si
yo quiero
entonces yo no tengo que nada tú no
tienes que nada no tienes que nada aquí
hay tres aristas de lo mismo creer fe y
talento quizás no haya ninguna
correlación pero yo quise hacerlo de
esta manera y sé esta pequeña gráfica
para ustedes
que le llame creer
90 por ciento bastan le pregunto y
ustedes si yo ofrezco el 90 por ciento
de lo que yo soy de mi capacidad en mi
empleo en mi trabajo en mi hogar el 90
por ciento es suficiente seguramente la
mayoría convendría en que sí que si es
suficiente incluso que es más que
suficiente y algunos dirán por encima de
la media estamos bien
de 50 en adelante estamos muy bien y
elevemos ese promedio hasta un 95% yo
les voy a poner un ejemplo simple
la mayoría de los que tienen una persona
sentada a su lado si le observan
[Música]
quizá consigan algún rasgo que les sea
familiar
y dice bueno yo voy a emprender con esta
persona una relación amorosa pasado un
mes decimos todo va bien y cuando nos
reunimos
yo quiero dar el siguiente paso y le
digo tú sabes que yo quiero dar el
siguiente paso contigo porque no vivimos
juntos vamos a darnos una oportunidad
como pareja y yo creo que yo la tengo
más que merecida porque yo el 90% de las
veces te he sido fiel en este mes que
tenemos juntos
qué creen ustedes qué va a suceder
siendo que ese 90 lo elevamos al cien
por ciento no hay garantía alguna de
éxito quizá no funciona y ya con el 100
por ciento imagínense ustedes dando el
90 por ciento entonces por qué en otras
aristas de lo que somos damos menos nos
conformamos con un 90 con un 80 con un
50 por ciento
en mi trabajo o en mi hogar doy menos es
la misma condición de infidelidad aquí
hay algunas palabras
la primera es viajando con papá aparece
y viajando con mi papá comienza mi
historia desde niño yo vengo de una
familia de cuatro hermanos
la preocupación de mi papá que todos los
fines de semanas largos fines de semana
que tuviéramos la oportunidad vacaciones
el vivir una experiencia viajar a algún
lugar de mi país
cuando yo tuve la oportunidad de salir
por primera vez de mi país yo conocía
casi cada rincón de mi país me había
bañado en muchos muchísimos ríos en
playas había conocido la selva de mi
país los llanos
viajando con papá desde bien joven crecí
con eso y cuando uno crece con algo que
le es tan familiar uno a veces piensa
que el resto del mundo es así y después
descubres distintas realidades
después le sigue la palabra talento
acompañada de mentira
yo soy músico desde muy temprana edad
comencé a presentar inquietudes
musicales desde que tenía algunos cuatro
años de edad
y cuando me escuchaban cantar desde muy
temprana edad
o ejecutar algún instrumento folklórico
de mi país me ponían la mano aquí en el
hombro y me decían tú tienes
todo
yo hoy día un poco más reposado de esa
experiencia de mi niñez de mi
adolescencia e incluso de principios de
mi adultez yo puedo tener la certeza de
que eso era una mentira si yo hubiese
abordado aquella persona que me dijo tú
tienes talento fulanita cumple 15 años
el fin de semana anda para que te con
cantes unas dos o tres canciones
yo tengo la certeza de que si yo le
hubiese dicho a esta persona
perfecto yo te voy a cantar las tres
canciones yo te voy a enviar un
presupuesto
presupuesto de que me habría dicho de
entrada
bueno voy a ir a cantar entonces te voy
a ofrecer un presupuesto de eso pero son
nada más tres canciones bueno tengo un
presupuesto por las tres canciones
bueno no sé de repente cantante una
porque es que no tenemos presupuesto
bueno entonces yo te puedo hacer una
oferta por esa canción pero yo te voy a
poner una mesa y va a haber comida iba a
haber bebida para ti qué bien que tengan
una atención conmigo quizás te haga una
mejor oferta y le dice sabes qué
[Música]
si hay tantos problemas mejor no vayas
para la fiesta mejor no vaya y
seguramente se va se habría ido hablando
mal de mí entonces esa persona que puso
aquí las manos sobre mi hombre y dice
tienes talento
yo hoy día sé que me dijo una mentira y
es porque eso no es un talento esa
persona reconoció un potencial en mí un
potencial talento que ya vamos a hablar
de eso más adelante y por eso yo lo
correlaciona con la palabra crecer y ahí
está seguida y subrayada insatisfacción
mi insatisfacción con mi entorno y esto
pasó más adelante entre mi juventud y
principios de mi adultez se me presentó
la oportunidad yo estaba brillando para
que el momento estaba haciendo asesor
comunicacional de una empresa me estaba
yendo muy bien pero mi insatisfacción me
llevó a viajar por por el sur de américa
y en este viaje por el sur
descubrí muchas cosas muchas inquietudes
pero dure varios meses viajando cuando
llegué me conseguí con la sorpresa
de que no tenía empleo pero por supuesto
no me iban a esperar varios meses y
llegar a mi empleo buenas de vídeo
hay un preámbulo allí que dice
exaltación y dice ven y yo lo quise
poner allí porque en mi viaje por el sur
quise hablar de exaltación un pueblecito
que quede en la ribera del río beni en
bolivia que ya tendría varios días
navegando por la selva antes de llegar
allí durmiendo arriba de sacos de arroz
y cuando llegó allí albéniz resulta que
fue una emoción que ese nombre es ese
ese pueblo ese poblado tiene muy bien
puesto el nombre exaltación yo estaba
tan feliz de llegar allí después de
varios días de no ver nada solo la selva
agua y más nada
me bañé en el río porque vi estaba
inundado el pueblo y sobresalía la
arquería de fútbol y yo dije sí a un
campo de fútbol todo tiene la misma
profundidad
ahí me bañé en la noche vi que le daban
el pésame a una señora que estaba
sentada y caminaban hacia un puerto
improvisado y veían un hoyo y decir que
veían resulta que en la mañana había
entrado una anaconda por allí se había
llevado a su hijo de ocho años y estaba
muy serena para ello es muy normal esto
yo dije que irresponsable como nos
dejaron bañarnos ahí en el río y se
soltaron una carcajada y me dieron para
que está en la ribera del río tú no
estás seguro en ninguna parte
esta era una realidad completamente
diferente que yo no había aterrizado en
lo que estaba viviendo regreso sin
empleo como les conté hace un momento
pero
desarrolle muchas ideas sobre talento
sobre potenciar ese talento y aprender a
vivir de ese talento y de ahí me fui a
la república dominicana y anduve por
varios núcleos de varias universidades
dictando conferencias sobre cómo
descubrir tu talento
potenciar ese talento y aprender a vivir
de ese talento porque ese es un reto
para los que lo conocen
esa es la pirámide de maslow y no voy a
profundizar mucho en esto pero
le puse fe en la juventud en la más alto
está la autorrealización le sigue el
reconocimiento en la mitad de la
pirámide el amor y relacionamiento
seguridad y en la base fisiología
necesidades básicas tengo mucha fe en la
juventud y ahorita vamos a aislar todo
esto que le estoy comentando que le
estoy compartiendo mucha fe en la
juventud porque cuando nos vemos con su
teléfono celular tomando 63 selfish
haciendo la misma mueca enseñando la
lengua decimos que esta generación no
tiene nada en la cabeza
yo por el contrario tengo muchísima más
fe en eso
mucha fe porque la mayoría ni siquiera
saben por qué lo hacen hay muchos
adultos que se suman a estas modas a
estas tendencias y eso está en el
segundo peldaño más alto
de arriba hacia abajo que es el
reconocimiento lo que yo busco cuando me
hago una self y ese reconocimiento es
que se me reconozca eso está por encima
de mis necesidades fisiológicas como
como las conocemos
seguridad por encima incluso del amor y
el relacionamiento
yo quiero ser reconocido por quién soy o
por lo que soy y en lo más alto está la
autorrealización o sea que yo diría que
esta juventud necesito un pequeño
empujoncito para ir más allá pero ha
sido muy difícil porque lo que te
promocionan por ser exitoso es que
tienes mucho
o mucho
sí mucho dinero o tienes muchas mujeres
lo cual es algo bien misógeno o tienes
una mansión
pero resulta que yo puedo tener la casa
más grande del mundo y eso solamente
está en seguridad en el segundo peldaño
lo más bajo
de la escalera de la pirámide de maslow
resulta que allí también está el que
dice tengo mucho dinero es de seguridad
también y no importa cuánto tengas y si
tengo muchas mujeres y presumo de esto
el mayor contacto que yo podría tener
con muchas mujeres sería única y
exclusivamente sexual y eso está en lo
más bajo eso es una necesidad
fisiológica entonces es muy difícil
decirle al a esa juventud en la que yo
tengo mucha fe que él sí quiere
reconocimiento ser reconocido y que lo
que hay es que en caminar un poquito
esto es ese ese genio esa experticia ese
talento hay una frase de beethoven que
dice el genio se compone 2% de talento y
98% de perseverante aplicación eso lo
dice beethoven no lo digo yo pero si yo
comparo hoy en día quien es un genio
cuantos de los que están acá conocen un
genio tú que me estás viendo desde la
comodidad de tu hogar cuantos genios
conoce que hay en tu comunidad en tu
trabajo no es fácil verdad determinar
quién es un genio
quien es un experto cuando yo profundizó
quien es un experto necesito por lo
menos tener 10 años en una disciplina
constante formándome y siendo destacado
en esto para decir soy un experto y si
tengo talento vamos a profundizar en
esto para tener maestría necesito tener
más prácticas mejores habilidades
mejores resultados y más disfrute pero
yo le pongo acá al lado prueba de
coeficiente intelectual dice muy poco de
quién eres pero así determinan el futuro
de la mayoría de nosotros con una prueba
de
coeficiente intelectual y sin mi
inquietud por lo menos y mi inteligencia
es musical o soy kinestésico que son los
que quieren hacer deportes yo no tengo
mucho que ofrecer para una prueba de
coeficiente intelectual y dice no sirve
la sociedad puede ser un genio pero no
estás ahí vamos a confrontar esto esta
realidad de la que estoy conversando
tengo los dones naturales y rasgos de mi
personalidad que si yo lo sumo con mi
experiencia y con mi pasión eso sí es
talento
son mis dones mi experiencia mi pasión
vamos a profundizar aún más en esto que
les estoy comentando eso que está ahí
con un asterisco rojo que dice talento
vamos a comenzar de lo simple a lo
complejo
lo que te encanta hacer a ti
y lo que el mundo necesita la suma de lo
que te encanta hacer lo que el mundo
necesita es tu misión
lo que el mundo necesita y por lo que te
van a pagar esa es tu vocación
y por lo que te van a pagar y lo que
haces bien esa es tu profesión
y cuando yo sumo tu profesión con tu
vocación eso es talento pero no basta
eso también tiene que haber una sinergia
tienen que converger con tu misión y tu
pasión entonces si yo sumo pasión misión
profesión y vocación eso sí es talento y
si me van a pagar por eso y si van a
reconocer que lo hago bien y si me
encanta hacerlo porque por eso está con
eso y el mundo lo necesita porque nada
hago siendo astronauta si estoy en un
sitio donde todos son ganaderos puedo
ser un experto en eso por eso este lo
complejo a lo simple y termino mi
proyecto así la vida es simple eres
feliz si sigue así
no algo debes cambiar muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]